hi welcome back so here I'm gonna go a
little bit more into depth on this
example of how to use the Koopman
operator to analyze nonlinear
differential equations in terms of
finite dimensional linear dynamical
systems on observable functions okay so
we have this nonlinear differential
equation here in two states the system
has a slow manifold here given by this
red dashed curve as long as lambda is
fast and stable compared to mu and we
have these white trajectories these
three different trajectories where you
start at different initial conditions
and rapidly they all move up to this
slow manifold and then they slowly move
down to the fixed point at 0 0 so in the
Koopman world i can create a new state
space where i'm measuring X 1 X 2 and X
1 squared these are my new variables
three of them and I can represent my
original nonlinear differential equation
in terms of a linear dynamical system on
these three observable functions which
is awesome so now we're gonna dig into
this matlab a little bit for how we can
actually visualize the solution to this
Koopman linear system in three
dimensions and i'm gonna tell you a
little bit about what these different
color manifolds mean okay
so here we have the simulation from from
the slides but now I'm going to be able
to rotate this any way I want which is
really neat okay so I want to tell you a
little bit about about these coordinate
systems and why we've chosen them and
what they mean so here we have y1 and y2
and those are just my x1 and x2
directions and then y3 this third
dimension is a measurement of x1 squared
okay so our SLO manifold that red dashed
parabola if you take that out of the X 1
X 2 plane and you move it through y3
because that should also be a slow
manifold regardless of y3 you get this
red parabola parabolic sheet and this
blue parabolic sheet is the set of
initial conditions that satisfy the fact
that if I have an initial condition at X
1 my initial condition for y3 had better
be x1 squared okay so this blue sheet is
essentially initial conditions should
start out on this blue sheet and notice
that I have these white trajectories
here these are my full initialized
trajectories of my Koopman linear system
and they move very quickly onto this
green slow subspace so now in the
Koopman system i still have these
eigenvalues mu and lambda and one of
them is still much faster than the other
so this green surface here is my my slow
subspace of the Koopman operator and
these white curves very rapidly attract
on to this green slow subspace and then
they follow it back down along this
parabolic trajectory to the fixed point
ok and you can see now this is a little
subtle but you can see that this green
slow subspace does not exactly line up
with this intersection of my blue and
red paraboloids so the blue and red
paraboloids are at 45 degrees
and my green Subspace is a little bit
more shallow and what you find this is
really interesting is that as you make
your fast dynamics that lambda as you
make it faster and faster and faster
this green manifold starts to incline up
and up and up until it perfectly aligns
with the intersection of my initial
condition blue manifold and my
asymptotic attractor this red slow
manifold so that's kind of cool you can
actually play around with this in the
code and make it faster or slower and
you'll see these things become more
aligned or less aligned but what's you
know what's really neat here is that
these white solutions in 3d are really
honest-to-goodness outputs of a linear
differential equation these are linear
trajectories in three dimensions and
when I project them down unto my y1 y2
subspace my state if you will my linear
measurements in my state you perfectly
agree with the nonlinear dynamics